how's it going everyone it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and i
am so excited that fans are loving
shanghi and if you saw it and you loved
it be sure to let me know what you
thought about it in the comments down
below or you can tweet at me on twitter
the movie was fantastic but that
post-credits scene has left people with
a lot of questions and needless to say
this is a breakdown of the post-credits
scene so if you don't want to know
anything about it this is your official
spoiler alert and you should probably
click away now but for those of you who
do want spoilers or simply answers let's
dive into it and of course if you love
marvel in the mcu be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of our
latest videos so the ending of shanghi
the very last scene that we see is of
shang chi and katie going with wang wang
appears he asks chongqi if he has the
ten rings he says yes and he tells him
and katie to go with him now the first
mid-credit scene takes place immediately
after this moment right here we see wang
using his magic to project the tin rings
in front of everybody this is very
similar to what we saw in the beginning
of avengers infinity war where wang used
the same type of magic to show and teach
tony stark and bruce banner about the
infinity stones now joining wang
shang-chi and katie is bruce banner and
captain marvel and notice that it is
actually bruce banner it is no longer
hulk or professor hulk like we saw in
avengers inn game somehow banner has
turned back into himself in pure human
form how did he do this well he is a
genius so he could have figured it out
himself combined with the hulk which was
professor hulk in in-game and it's
probably a story that we're going to
hear about when the she-hulk series
comes on on disney plus now the fact
that professor hulk is now just bruce
banner and carol danvers now has long
hair not that short hair that we saw in
in-game tells us that some time has
passed since the events of avengers
in-game and they're gathered here via
the same projection technology that we
saw in in-game and they're gathered for
a pretty significant reason they are
trying to figure out what exactly the 10
rings are and where they came from now
in the movie they don't actually tell us
how winwoo got the rings and this is
very intentional because they're going
to reveal this to us later down the line
he say that maybe he found them or took
them from a tomb but as it turns out
these rings are actually a lot older
than when wu was chiang chi says that
his father had them for about a thousand
years but then bruce banner says that
they're older than that by a lot and
that line right there is really
important and i'll come back to that in
just a second so they're trying to
figure out where they came from what
they're made out of and wong says they
don't match anything in their codex and
this is huge because consider the
knowledge that the ancient one had
considered the knowledge that wang has
all of the books about other realms
about other parts of the universe they
even have knowledge and weapons of
cosmic entities in doctor strange we saw
the staff of the living tribunal a
cosmic entity so the fact that the rings
don't match anything that wong would
have access to is big bruce banner then
confirms that they're not made out of
vibranium the super rare metal from
wakanda that captain america's shield is
made out of and that black panther suit
is made out of as well captain marvel
confirms that they're not chatari tech
chitari are some of the creatures that
make up thanos army that we saw in
avengers and then again in avengers
infinity war and end game so they can't
figure out where they're from or what
they're made out of but there is one
thing that they did figure out the rings
sent out a beacon the second that
chongqi took control over them so
obviously the big question is who did it
send out the beacon to well one thing
that you might have noticed about the
rings is that the whole entire time when
when woo uses them they're blue however
when xiang chi uses them they're gold so
when shengqi took the rings for the very
first time and they became gold instead
of blue this was most likely the beacon
being activated shanxi fought win woo
and whenever when wu would take the
rings they would turn back blue so
clearly there is something a little bit
different about shang chi than his
father win woo perhaps the rings can
sense the character of a person and
perhaps this is somewhat like mjolnir
thor's hammer with its worthiness
enchantment either way the rings seemed
to have a mind of their own and the
second chiang chi took the rings it sent
out a beacon now colors actually play a
pretty big significance in the mcu
especially when it's concerning the
mystic magical side of the mcu the
mystic arts and normal magic that doctor
strange and the other sorcerers use are
orange the dark magic that is pulled
from the dark realms are typically
darker colors like the dark purple we
saw agatha hartness use in one division
and gold typically is cosmic energy we
haven't really seen this much but we
have seen it recently in the eternals in
the trailers we can see a lot of gold
magic being used but of course to them
it's almost like science it's kind of
like what thor said in the very first
thor movie where he's from asgard magic
and science are pretty much one and the
same so when we're talking about who
made these rings it looks like they
could be coming from a cosmic entity now
in the comics the rings are very very
different than what we saw in the movie
for starters they are actual rings that
go on your fingers and each ring has a
different ability this is not like we
saw in the movie in the movie they kind
of all have the same ability and in the
comics the rings are mccluentech who are
an alien species their spacecraft
crashes into earth one day and then the
mandarin the character that win woo is
based off of steals them from the crash
site now i don't think the mcluhans are
going to be the actual creators of the
rings in the mcu but i do think the
creators are coming from a distant part
in space specifically for two reasons
one is because of what bruce banner said
bruce banner said that they're older
than a thousand years by a lot now we
learned from the eternals trailer that
the eternals have been on the planet for
about seven thousand years and we can
assume that they were pretty much there
during the beginning of the earth's
creation so the rings could have been
made well before actual people and
civilizations were established on the
planet and since cosmic entities can
live thousands and millions of years old
it's definitely possible that one of
them created these so how old they are
and the fact that they seem to emit
cosmic energy at least when shanxi is
using them really points to a cosmic
being making them and that wouldn't be
the first time that we actually saw this
happen in the mcu like i mentioned in
doctor strange we saw the staff of the
living tribunal so weapons created by
cosmic entities already exist within the
mcu and it seems very likely especially
since this sent off a beacon that these
were indeed created by some gigantic
cosmic god bean now again back to the
question who the first time that i saw
this i immediately heard beacon and
thought galactus galactus the devourer
of planets is a cosmic entity and he
does have what's known as the power
cosmic the power cosmic is a vast source
of essentially limitless godly power
cosmic power and according to the silver
surfer a herald of galactus he says that
to wield the power cosmic is to be in
touch with every other living thing at
once this could actually be a reason as
to why the rings changed colors when
shang chi wielded them perhaps galactus
was somehow in touch with shanxi and win
woo or perhaps the rings if they contain
any of the similar powers that the power
cosmic have were actually aware as well
and sent a beacon in the comics as most
people know galactus has heralds and
their primary job is to go and scope out
planets and energy for galactus to come
and devour and when his heralds get to a
planet that is suitable for galactus
they send out a beacon essentially this
beacon alerts galactus and it basically
says hey man i found a good planet for
you to munch on and galactus actually
bestows part of the power cosmic on each
of his heralds and each herald kind of
gets different abilities for example the
silver surfer had his board it is
possible that the rings are a product of
the power cosmic and they were actually
a weapon wielded by a herald of galactus
if this was the case it would still
wield part of the power cosmic which
would send a beacon back to galactus so
if this theory turns out to be correct
then the avengers and essentially a lot
of the universe has a big problem cause
galactus is coming but there is another
option that i think might actually be
more likely since bruce banner did say
they predate a thousand years by a lot
that could actually line up right with
the eternals being on the earth for
about seven thousand years now the
eternals were created by the cosmic gods
the celestials and again the celestials
and the eternals all use cosmic energy
it is very clear that some weapons were
formed by the eternals and possibly by
the celestials and it is also possible
that some weapons could have may have
been stolen or misplaced along that 7
000 years or locked away somewhere in a
not so secure location leading
ultimately to win woo finding them and
the beacon very well could be a beacon
to the celestials and this probably
isn't good considering the fact that the
only celestials that we've seen in the
mcu so far do appear to be evil we have
ego star lord's father from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2. he wanted to
essentially destroy the universe then we
have esson the searcher from the very
first guardians of the galaxy we see him
destroying a planet then we also have
nowhere the head of a celestial now in
the comics null is the one that cut off
the head of the celestial however null
has a direct relationship with symbiotes
and venom and i don't think that's going
to be in the mcu so more than likely
another celestial ended this celestial's
life and cut off its head so this could
be a beacon to one of the celestials and
if that is the case that is probably not
good and i think we'll definitely find
out a lot more about the celestials and
maybe even a glimpse at what the tin
rings are and where they're from in the
eternals one thing is for sure that
whoever this beacon is being sent to
probably isn't good news for earth
xiangxi and the avengers and the final
part of this mid-credit scene is of wang
shang-ji and katie partying singing
hotel california which is the song that
katie used to distract one of the ninjas
i'll call them when they were fighting
in that scaffolding scene but then we
get the post credit scene which is about
xailing now at the end of shanghqi
chongqi says that his sister is
dismantling what is left of the 10 rings
however the post credit scene shows us
otherwise his sister zylene is actually
now in charge of the 10 rings and we can
see two familiar faces beside her john
john which helped her run her little
fight club in macau and razer fist her
father's right hand man for a little
while zailing says that they have a lot
of work to do and then the camera
expands and we see that she has actually
expanded the ten rings as well she now
not only has an army of males but also
females and this of course is due to the
fact that her father never let her
because she was a girl trained with the
boys but now the empire is hers and
she's going to do it her way now will
xylene actually be very bad we're not
really sure at this point i think it
might be one of those things where she
has to do bad to do good kind of like
yeah i have to kill a bunch of people
but these people are kind of bad so it's
alright however it does seem like she's
pretty bitter having gone through what
she's gone through in life and it
definitely seems like she does have some
sort of an agenda and this is also
proven by the very last thing that says
the ten rings will return and those are
the two post-credit scenes for shang chi
be sure to let me know what you thought
about shang chi in the comments down
below and of course for more shang qi
videos and marvel videos be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram or twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof